un llamado de atención a los aliados
kiev no deja de subrayar lo que puede
significar para su seguridad e
integridad territorial la aprobación de
su membresía en la otan y la Unión
Europea dos socios que trabajan en el
fortalecimiento de las capacidades
defensivas de Ucrania en el contexto de
la invasión rusa
el verano en la Cumbre de la otan en
vilnas se necesita una invitación Clara
de membresía para Ucrania así como
garantías de seguridad en el camino
hacia la otan también son necesarias en
el otoño se necesita decisión Clara y
positiva sobre nuestro acceso a la Unión
Europea los miembros de la otan están
divididos en su decisión de abrir las
puertas a Ucrania sin embargo las
consecuencias de una presunta aceptación
a la alianza del Atlántico Norte
plantearía un escenario poco halagador
para Rusia el artículo 5 de la
organización conocido como defensa
colectiva plantea que un ataque armado
contra una de las Naciones firmantes se
considera un ataque dirigido contra
todos los miembros en este sentido qué
buscaría el presidente de Ucrania la
respuesta iría más en la historia Por
qué Porque básicamente lo que Ucrania
buscaría con su adicción a la otan es
una garantía de seguridad no en este
momento porque en este momento la
decisión de Ucrania está simplemente
cerrada en ningún país miembro de la
otan como organización quieren un
enfrentamiento directo con Rusia Por lo
cual en este momento la anexión de
Ucrania es imposible Por ende
exacerbarca conflicto tampoco pero en un
futuro la idea de Ucrania Es que la otan
sea una garantía de que Rusia nunca más
intente lo que lo que lo que está
haciendo ahora con el territorio
ucraniano sin embargo las posiciones
antagónicas más Rusia no dejarían de ver
el hecho como una ampliación agresiva
que pone en peligro sus intereses